i don't know how like online you are but
there was a big mephisto conversation
around wanda vision
um and we were all going nuts so 14
minutes of the first episode there's
this moment where i could have sworn
that's where the episode was going yeah
you know that's interesting i was just
reading about that character it'd be
interesting if you ever showed up in the
mcu
was that an intentional like thing to
rile up fans or am i just still stuck in
like what happened around one division
it's honestly just a super weird
coincidence
like it's genuinely a reference to loki
you know
the horns he fell from you know he was
cast out of heaven that's what it's a
reference to
but yeah because i mean we filmed that
like a long time before
you know i think one division must have
been in post when we filmed that so
yeah i did see all the stuff about that
online and i was like oh
this is going to be interesting but no
it's more relevant to the themes of our
show and it's not
it's not a nod to that character
[Music]
come on what did you expect
wandavision was such a wonderful
exploration of grief falcon and winter
soldier about identity
what would you say that loki is the
exploration of
so for me a really central theme is is
anyone truly good
or bad and that gray area in between and
um you know like are we always going to
be defined by our past actions or can we
move past those and i think loki for me
he's the perfect example of that gray
area right and he flips between good and
bad
constantly and i think that is
definitely a central question
not just with loki but across the entire
show it's about
you know who what what makes a villain a
villain what makes a hero a hero and
can you be both uh it's
that's the cool thing is is movies sort
of have to
big big blockbuster superhero movies we
sort of have to play in the
good and evil sort of thing tv there's
more time and you get to
to play in the shades of gray and i
think that's where loki's always lived
and so i think it's about loki further
just examining
who he is as a character and why he is
the way he is
we love loki and he's we've kind of
always seen him like
paired with thor or kind of like
tethered to like the asgard
stuff how different is it this time
around now that he's kind of away from
all of that what would you say the
biggest like differences from what we've
seen in the past
well he's on his own and so so he's got
a
he's got a fin for himself he doesn't he
doesn't have anybody else he can
he can look to take advantage of
to get out of jams and everything you
know and and it
doesn't have anybody he can blame things
on the messes he's making now are his
own
um and that's not to say that he was
ever passing the buck
it's just this is a guy who's always
really been connected to thor
and really sort of survived
by being close to power
and then seeking to overthrow that power
now he's on his own at the bottom of a
ladder at the bottom of a food chain
and so it's just a totally new dynamic
for him to to be
playing with he's had one of the best
arcs across the last 10 years of the mcu
and you know i think but we're not we
don't have that guy that we had
you know that we saw in infinity war
with the guy from endgame who's
obviously avengers loki
and i think the exciting thing for me as
a storyteller is that
he's in a very different headspace to
the loki we've seen over the last 10
years and
you know we're putting you know god of
mischief into this bureaucratic kind of
organization and
how is he going to cope within that
place so yeah i think we're taking him
to a very
new corner of the mcu and i think yeah
and there's a lot of fun to be had with
that
so the real key thing for me and the
writing team at marvel was just
there has to be a good reason to go back
in with this character
and definitely taking him to new places
but paying respect to you know the
character that's come before because he
is so beloved
tom obviously you know brings full like
tom to this like he cracks me up in the
first few episodes so
he obviously knows this character inside
and out how closely did you two work
together because i saw he's also
executive producing like
did you have these moments where tom
would be like oh loki would actually say
this or anything like that that you can
think of
yeah of course tom and i worked really
closely and became
great pals that was one of the great
pleasures of the show
he he came uh to the writers room
and sat with all of us um and just
spent a full day uh answering questions
talking about the character talking
about you know
the motivations behind choices he made
in the very first thor movie
uh when he was shaping the character
with kenneth branagh 10 years ago and
then
after the writer's room wrapped when i
was rewriting all the episodes tom and i
we had a couple of marathon breakfasts
i would say uh around la when he was in
town
just talking about the character you
know how would loki say certain things
tom's english i'm from georgia
so there were it's like all right let's
make sure loki doesn't quite sound like
he's from the south
uh and and so we were refining it
together but
that was an amazing collaboration a
really key thing for us was talking
about the memories that loki sees
in the time theater and something that
tom was saying that he
he definitely was contributing to that
discussion because we were like trying
to make sure you know like
it's important that you know we had that
moment with frigger and
like but there was also other moments
like the hopeful moments like i'm
here and tom was very like you know like
we had these amazing actors and tom is
an encyclopedia of loki knowledge so it
was amazing to have his input into that
endgame did the time travel the time
heist and of course it was like
so debated and dissected by the fandom
so i
just i don't even know if you can like
put this into like a brief sentence but
like wrapping your head around like
the time concept was that something that
you would like
spring up at night and be like oh wait
god that doesn't make sense i gotta go
rewrite that part
yeah i would not even sleep at night
that's there was nothing to spring up
from
uh i was so stressed that was certainly
probably the biggest challenge of the
show
was um in game was a movie
about time travel but ultimately when
that movie's over you get to walk out
and it's like well
it made sense and it all worked but this
is a tv show
and and our time travel logic is gonna
have to sustain
week by week and that means a week of
scrutiny by the fans
uh between every episodes as they should
it's exactly what i would do if i was
watching this and so
that meant that in the writers room we
were drawing a lot of lines with other
squiggly lines coming off of them
on the white boards because we had to
essentially create a a foundational
knowledge of time travel in the room in
the writers room that we've that the tva
was gonna work off of
and invent the rules of time travel
so they could then be broken that was a
fun but challenging part of the job
please like at some point you need to
like release the all the squiggles i
need to see like all of these like maps
that you're
making because i'm sure it's amazing
yeah i don't know
if what's funny is they all probably
look the same except
all of our writers all of whom could all
start
arguments with one another even a year
and a half on about no that's right
that's right so
yeah that was it was fun uh to be a fly
on the wall
the mystery of db cooper keeps me up at
night and we finally have our answer i
have to know how this idea came up
because i thought it was so funny
i mean the truth is if it wasn't going
to be don draper it was going to have to
be loki
yeah that's a story that i love that's
such like amazing american folklore
and in that moment what happened to be
the perfect way to sort of illustrate
why does the tva not interfere with that
sort of thing
uh helps prove mobius's point um
and kate you know she just shot the hell
out of that and and really it's it's
this just amazing little
detour uh that's that was
i never i remember when i wrote it i was
like well you know you never quite know
if that'll make it in
but it made it in and we're so glad it
did we got to pour one out for casey
i think he's going to be a fan favorite
of everybody i love him
yup yup he's yeah eugene's amazing he's
he brings
some great little levity to that based
on a
a character in the comics who's just a
at the tva
he's just an alien who wears a train
conductor hat
and i didn't know he was actually from
the comics that's great
he's just a lesser a very i think has
one line but we always laughed about him
and so
you know kate casey he's got a he's near
and dear to all of our hearts